villains villains and more villains
every year New York Comic-Con offers
interesting glimpses into the not so
distant future of entertainment this
year Star Trek fans have more than a
little to be happy about thanks to a new
teaser trailer for the upcoming Star
Trek Picard season 3. the brand new New
York Comic-Con teaser for the new Picard
season revolves around a shocking
distress call Admiral Jean-Luc Picard
receives from Beverly Crusher and an
extra threatening villain known as vatic
however that's just the beginning of
Picard's troubles this time around even
by Star Trek Picard standards there are
some extremely intriguing character
reveals here and they have fans all
saying the same thing Professor James
Moriarty makes his grand entrance in the
teaser saying greetings old friends
armed with a smirk and icy cold stare
and a gun the Hologram Sherlock Holmes
villain from Star Trek the Next
Generation isn't the only bad guy from
the show to re-emerge in the season 3
teaser either just when you thought
everything was over lore stares down the
heroes with an extremely unamused look
on his face fans have reacted to the
news of the villains return with a
combination of surprise and delighted
Intrigue one redditor wrote about
Moriarty that was a TNG villain I would
have never guessed about coming back at
this point another agreed saying
Moriarty is my favorite character from
Star Trek so you can only imagine my
reaction when he appeared I would have
never expected that Laura Drew similar
comments from fans a Reddit commenter
wrote I called where is lore before the
first season came out didn't think it
would actually pan out other corners of
the internet also took note of the
villain reveals a YouTube commenter
wrote holy Moriarty and lore hopefully
this will be the send-off the TNG crew
so rightly deserves meanwhile over on
Twitter one user couldn't hide their
exclamation mark heavy excitement
writing OMG just watch the trailer for
Picard season 3 Moriarty and lore are
back I can hardly wait both returning
villains have deep ties to Star Trek the
Next Generation protagonists the Star
Trek version of James Moriarty is
actually a highly ambitious hologram
that was originally created by Jordi
laforge but soon becomes a self-aware
bad guy meanwhile lore is data's fellow
sung type Android who's well
significantly less friendly than his
more famous compatriot while neither
Moriarty nor lore are one and done
villain of the weak types they both have
but a small handful of episodes under
their belts two for Moriarty and four
for lore as such they're both known
enemies that long time fans can get
excited about yet easily deep enough
cuts to offer all sorts of fascinating
options for Picard season 3. judging by
their ominous stairs in the trailer
everyone who gets in their way is
definitely in for a deliciously bad time
the return of these old villains
continues Picard's all but stated
mission to revisit the vast majority of
the Next Generation characters minor and
major alike and in Laura's case spiner's
continued tendency to constantly portray
new characters in the show how the evil
Android and the Hologram Napoleon of
crime fit in the grand scheme of things
remains to be seen But fans can already
rest assured that Picard season 3 will
feature a pretty neat Rogues gallery
foreign